OK, we now have received our first postdebate
polling between Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
And it is really, really bad for Donald Trump.
Not so bad that we can stay home now.
We still have to vote, but it is bad.
A new NBC Wall Street Journal poll has Donald
Trump 14.
That is not a typo, 14 points behind Joe Biden,
53 to 39.
Among registered voters, there is also an
IBD poll which says it's Biden only plus three.
There is a poll from the Hill that has Biden
plus seven.
And there's a new CNBC poll that has Biden
plus 13.
Those are the four post debate polls we had
as of this morning.
Among those polls, the average Biden lead
is nine point three.
The official Real Clear Politics average is
Biden plus eight point one.
And this plus 14 for Biden in the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll is almost a doubling of
Biden's lead in that same poll since the last
time it was done.
What's very interesting about that particular
poll is that the NBC Wall Street Journal poll
tends to track the sort of average of all
polls.
So if you have a range of polls saying a candidate
is anywhere from plus two to plus 10 and the
average is five.
Usually the NBC poll is right in with the
average.
That poll now says Joe Biden is winning by
14.
So we really are seeing a difference between
2016 and 2020 polling now.
As I mentioned today, October five, Joe Biden
is plus eight point one on average back in
2016 on this date, October five.
Hillary Clinton was only ahead by three point
nine.
So, of course, we've got to be careful.
The polls could be off.
Everybody has to vote, voter suppression,
et cetera.
But the idea that the numbers now are just
like 2016 is no longer true.
Joe Biden's lead today is about 110 percent
larger than Hillary Clinton's was in 2016.
So what does that mean?
It means we vote.
It means we try to make those numbers a reality.
It very much does not mean we can check out
and not worry.
If Donald Trump does recover relatively quickly
from Corona virus, they will paint him as
some kind of heroic savior.
They will push everything they can to make
the case that strong hero Trump is the person
we need.
They will suppress the vote.
They will do all of it.
But right now, it's looking really bad for
Trump.
In the meantime, as another data point, the
538 2020 projection has slightly ticked up.
You'll remember about a month ago, Joe Biden
had about a 70 percent chance to win.
It is now 81.
Does it change anything about what we need
to do?
No.
A month ago, in a hundred simulations, Trump
would win in 30.
Now Trump wins 19.
But so what?
There's still a one in five chance.
And it's too great a risk to become even one
iota complacent at this time.
In terms of the popular vote, again, RCP has
it.
Biden eight point one ahead 538 has it.
Biden seven point to ahead.
That's big for 538.
So now we vote.
The other question is what will the Trump
Kova diagnosis due to the polling?
Anyone who would vote based on which candidate
has covered is already voting for Trump is
my take.
I don't believe Trump's sycophants will abandon
him because he got covered.
I also don't think Trump is going to gain
sympathy voters because he got clobbered.
I think it cancels out what you could have.
Are people for whom Trump getting covered
could be the final straw in terms of Trump's
disregard for the virus.
Those could be people who well abandon Trump
over his complete mishandling of the situation.
We may have polls today or potentially tomorrow
that are post Trump's diagnosis.
We will see what they say and we will have
those numbers for you on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show.
David Pakman dot com.
Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
So the latest update I have as of this moment
and to not talk about it would be weird, but
I have to acknowledge that things are moving
very quickly and we may have different news
by the time you listen to today's show.
The news is that Donald Trump may be going
home soon.
Today, he may already be home or maybe not.
He still is scheduled to have a rally tonight,
which is just completely inconceivable.
Obviously, if he did it, it would be some
kind of remote thing.
He would be joining me via remote video.
Donald Trump, of course, is is not traveling
to a rally tonight, but he's either doing
well or not doing well.
We just don't know.
We are left to try to infer and to try to
wade through the lies.
But one thing we have in black and white is
that this morning Donald Trump sent 20, 20
consecutive completely manic tweets in a very
short period of time from the hospital, almost
all in capital letters.
And once again, this could be anything.
Is Trump tweeting because he's panicked that
the latest polls are really bad?
Is he simply manic from the dexamethasone?
Kordic corticosteroid induced mania is not
an uncommon side effect of dexamethasone and
other steroids.
We just don't know.
But the tweets are completely outrageous.
Take a look at just some of these.
As you can see here, Donald Trump tweeting,
Most of these are all caps.
Stock market highs vote.
Virginia voters, your governor wants to obliterate
your Second Amendment.
I have stopped him.
If you want a massive tax increase, the biggest
in the history of our country and one that
will shut our economy and jobs down.
Vote Democrat.
I'm voting for Donald Trump.
My father is a union worker and his four one
K has tripled under President Trump.
Obviously, the stock market hasn't tripled.
So if the four on K has tripled, maybe the
person started contributing three times as
much, sort of a non sequitur than just another
string of all caps, tweets, pro-life vote,
massive regulation cuts vote space force vote.
Best V.A ever, 91 percent approval rating.
Vote for a one K vote.
Biggest tax cut ever.
And another one coming.
Vote.
Religious liberty.
Both law and order.
Vote.
Peace through strength.
Save our Second Amendment.
Vote.
Fight the corrupt fake news media.
Protect preexisting conditions.
Vote better and cheaper health care.
Vote so completely out of control.
Could this be a combination of a steroid add
up? Trump seeing the latest NBC poll, which
has him down by 14 points to Joe Biden and
simply doing what he feels he can do from
a hospital.
Our friend Faren Cousins from Ring of Fire
wrote to me on Twitter, Most likely it's the
steroids.
I've been on them before for severe asthma
and they can make you very angry and aggressive.
Has someone again lost control of Trump?
It is all speculation brought on by the reality
that Trump's behavior doesn't make any sense
and his doctors aren't.
We aren't being honest.
And this administration hasn't been honest
about Trump's health since day one.
And Trump lies about everything.
Dexamethasone, rare side effect of the drug
includes grandiose delusions.
How would you be able to tell the difference
with this guy?
And some experts have expressed concern about
the combinations of things Trump has gotten,
as you now know.
Trump received an unapproved antibody cocktail
rham deaths severe and dexamethasone at minimum
that we know of.
Dr. Thomas McGinn from the New York state
health provider Northwest Health said to The
New York Times that the kitchen sink is being
thrown at Donald Trump.
And Dr. Vin Gupta said, you don't start dexamethasone
rham death severe and an antibody treatment
that is yet unapproved.
If the president just slightly has a lower
oxygen level, you do it when there's Cauvin
pneumonia or something more serious.
Will we ever know the truth?
I really don't know.
We certainly don't know it right now.
And we've certainly never gotten the truth
on a whole bunch of other things that have
happened during the last four years.
So we may never know.
Next, we are going to talk about more overt
doctoring of the tapes, as the case may be.
So the propaganda games continue from the
White House.
They've now released a video where it is all
but completely obvious that a violent cough
by Donald Trump has been edited out of the
video and done really poorly.
This is part of the propaganda campaign that
they've been waging since Donald Trump went
to Walter Reed Hospital very quickly.
They sat Trump in front of a camera.
They had him deliver what they claimed was
a one take, very powerful four minute video
proving how well he's doing and how strong.
Yes, but it became immediately obvious that
at least at one point in this video, there
is what appears to be a jump cut.
Something appears to be just cut out.
And Donald Trump looks to be gagging when
it is done.
And the only logical conclusion we can reach
is that Trump coughing was removed from the
video.
So this is I acknowledge this is tough for
our audio audience.
You can find the video on my Twitter.
I'm going to first play the whole thing for
you.
And you'll notice that at the word therapeutics,
you hear something weird and you see Donald
Trump look almost like he's gagging or dry
heaving.
But it's very, very quick and it appears to
be a cough that was removed.
If you look closely, you'll also see Trump's
fingers jump because they did a poor job of
editing out the cough.
Take a look.
If you look at the therapeutics, which I'm
taking right now, some of the.
So now let's actually isolate the moment we're
talking about and play it without audio.
And again, I understand this is very visual
and that if you're only listening, it's hard
to understand what what we're seeing here.
But I did tweet this.
You can find it on my Twitter at David Pakman.
And as you can see, Trump seems to start to
gag or dry heave, but then it skips.
And Trump's finger twitches.
And so, as usual, the question is less about
the importance of this particular edit and
more about the constant gaslighting of the
American people to submit to to force them
to submit to a completely fabricated and concocted
narrative.
Trump's case of Corona virus has been stage
managed in a completely dishonest way for
optics and public relations appearances.
Christopher or is a contributing writer for
The Atlantic and Forbes tweeted that there
is clearly an edit on this video.
Experienced editors are saying that what is
in your dhobis suite called a Morfe cut tool
was used to remove Trump's violent cough from
the video.
So we need to be making sure that we're asking
the right questions when we talk about something
like this.
Why would the White House think they have
to do this?
Because of who Trump supporters are.
Trump can't just be sick from a serious virus.
That's not the right story.
Trump must be able to deliver four minutes
of uncut narrative to the audience about how
he's doing great.
Trump must not cough because for seven months,
more than that now, eight months, he's been
downplaying this as if it's no big deal.
Because if Trump was seriously ill, it probably
is the nail in the coffin of the approval
of Trump.
On Corona virus handling, which is already
very, very low.
If even Trump gets seriously ill, who could
be the most protected person in the world?
It also goes to the laziness of this administration
and of Donald Trump.
You could easily cover this by having Trump
stop.
Go back one line, film it from a different
angle, like from the side, for example.
It would look like a dramatic film making
decision and no one would be the wiser.
But they insist or Trump insists or Trump
is refusing to redo it.
They insist on doing the one take and then
cutting it out.
Cutting the cough out.
It is the most childish stage managing that
we've seen not only immoral to keep gaslighting
the American people about his condition, but
also done in a very unprofessional way.
It's a very childish, obvious, detectable
manner.
This is what we've gotten handed to us.
And this administration, I guess, thought
they could get away with it.
They didn't.
And they still think that they're going to
get away with getting this man reelected.
They may be right.
They may be wrong.
It is ultimately up to us to make sure that
it doesn't happen.
And that is why none of this means anything
other than go and vote.
There is not every news story.
Oh, there is a conflict in Armenia.
Oh, Trump's cutting out a cough from his video.
Oh, Joe Biden tested negative for rotavirus
a third time.
Fortunately, he did as of today.
It all means you go and you vote.
It all means you go to vote, dawg, and you
figure out my voting early in person.
Am I voting by mail?
Am I voting on November 3rd?
If so, where?
What are the rules?
Can somebody tell me that I need to get out
of line?
What what exactly is the plan?
That's all that we have to do.
We hear, oh, Trump's attacking China again.
We've got to vote.
That is the one answer here.